demon souls is a decent game there is a
lot to love about this game like its
level design and intriguing plots but
there's also quite a bit that can be
considered disappointing both the bosses
and npcs from both a gameplay and
backstory perspective are hit or miss
the beauty of the souls games when it
comes to story is reading item
descriptions and putting together
environmental details to be able to
uncover the whole story and while demon
souls definitely does that it's not as
consistent as you would expect many of
the bosses have the same backstory which
not only makes this idea overplayed but
also uninspiring and the npcs are
completely hit or miss as they're either
really great characters with interesting
ideas and values or completely pointless
there is still quite a bit to love about
this game and when the game does
something good it does it really well it
has some great level design that syncs
up with the tone it's trying to portray
making the locations you're in feel
believable and the initial plot of the
game is intriguing enough to get you in
that comfortable feeling that you're
back in a souls game again due to how
mysterious the actual story is which is
why it's such a shame that it's
surrounded by a wall of the
aforementioned mediocre boss backstory
and npc personality it's hard to not
have expectations when going into a game
so it's not the fact that having
expectations is the problem it's how
high those expectations are that is the
problem i went into this game with as
little of that as i could because i was
aware that this was the first
installment things could be bare bones
in a sense so i wasn't expecting
something close to the modern souls
games but despite that i was still left
a little disappointed but to explain we
should probably get playing so let's get
started and also since this video is the
final one in our soul series at least
for the time being stick around to the
end of the video if you want to know
what i plan to discuss next so demon
souls waste zero time getting started
even before the title screen pops up
we're showing a cutscene that details
some of the story it says that one day
man was granted a soul and then the
following day a soul devouring demon was
born the game doesn't let us know any
more than this but that's because the
actual intro cinematic is shown after
creating our character it states that
king allant the current ruler of the
kingdom of boletaria found a way to
channel the power of souls this brought
unprecedented power and prosperity to
the kingdom but also brought with it a
deep fog this fog cut off bulataria from
the rest of the world and trapped all
those inside but this fog hasn't just
cut off bola taria from the rest of the
world it's also spreading and will
eventually consume the world if the old
one isn't put to rest in an attempt to
escape this nightmare a man known as
valorfax of the twin fangs was the only
one to make it out and use the
opportunity to warn those of the
impending doom that doom of course being
the creature we just mentioned the old
one this old one is the sole devouring
demon i mentioned earlier upon being
awoken from its slumber it awoke other
demons that devoured those with souls
but these demons also had souls the more
these demons consumed the more power
that they'd receive and thus had
stronger souls called demon souls this
power that the demons had within them
was enticing enough for some individuals
to cross the fog to bulletaria and hopes
of power while many are unnamed the list
of people we do know is bjor the other
twin fang yurt the silent chief saint
urbain scurvier the wander santa strya
and her night girl vinland and sage
freak these characters also happen to be
the npcs of the game and even though
that sounds like a lot there are still
more that weren't mentioned but don't
get too wrapped up in their names as
we'll discuss them later our character
is just like the aforementioned npcs a
person who came to buletaria in search
of power and just like the other games
we aren't given a name only a title the
slayer of demons just from the intro you
can see how far back the roots of this
franchise go demon souls was the first
game to introduce the idea of beings
having souls and how the world is in a
constant cycle once the cutscene
finishes we can start the game and this
tutorial area is not only to get the
player accustomed to the game but it's
also a death trap as you're not allowed
to leave the area alive the final enemy
of the level is a demon known as the
vanguard it'll more than likely kill you
but even if you survive the game will
have a cutscene of you getting killed by
another demon but instead of it having a
simple you-dyed text pop-up at the
bottom it talks about how the player is
getting trapped in the nexus shortly
after we're then reborn but only as a
soul and while we can live on we're
stuck here for eternity once again the
themes that are consistent across the
various souls games originated here like
the idea of rebirth being a curse like
in dark souls being trapped in the world
until the objective is complete like the
hunter's dream and bloodborne and even
the concept of a fog separating the
kingdom from the world like an elden
ring with the lands between although
that could have just been a design
decision regardless playing demon souls
first or last has its benefits as you
can see what the game started with and
see how those grow over time or see
those growths first and then find out
how they started both of which showcase
how demon souls really revolutionized
the souls franchise even though every
other game is more well-known and
possibly more critically acclaimed than
demon souls there is still a lot of
praise that needs to be given as it was
the game that truly started all this was
also the reason i was so drawn to demon
souls in the first place i wanted to see
the series origin and this introduction
initially had me excited as i felt
comfortable despite the game having the
potential to go in a wildly different
direction due to it being the first
attempt i felt right at home like i was
visiting an old friend even though i've
never played demon's souls up until this
point from the moment i started playing
the game it felt natural to me not just
in gameplays that's pretty obvious but
in its narrative it was a new world with
new ideas and themes but have helped
strangely familiar and it's because of
the future games taking these ideas that
demon souls had started with and
tweaking them into their own stories
that caused me to feel this way many
credit dark souls 1 is the game that
truly created the genre and in a way
they're not wrong but it's important to
remember that demon souls still had a
hand in its creation and thus needs to
be recognized as such the first initial
thought you may have when entering the
nexus is how do we escape well
eventually we will meet the monumental a
being who existed back during the first
demon scourge and will tell us how they
managed to quell the old one the
monumental is also assumed to be the
person responsible for trapping the
slayer of demons here in the first place
as we hear its voice when crossing the
fog during his time the world was united
under the rule of soul arts but just
like with king alant and boletaria the
learning of the soul arts awoke the old
one but they were able to put the old
one back to sleep but only after half
the world had been destroyed in order to
mend the world back together they
created these six arch stones that were
looked over by the six rulers all the r
stones were put in place across the
earth but all met at the nexus since
underneath the nexus is the old one when
we meet with the monumental we'll see
other monumentals like them but they've
all died it's possible that the
monumental either put his faith in us
because he believes that we can defeat
the old one like they did or he's
forcing us here for his own gain
regardless it seems that the decision to
keep us in the nexus was non-consensual
just like the monumental if we actually
succeed and put the old one to sleep we
become a monumental a half-living being
that holds the fabric of the world
together so maybe the monumental wanted
more monumentals to be born so they can
keep up their numbers to defeat the old
one we need to conquer the archdemons
that reside in the arch stones once
they're defeated we can then go beneath
the nexus where the old one resides and
put it to sleep i keep mentioning this
idea of putting it to rest as we'll
eventually see the old one is a giant
creature and is presumably immortal so
it cannot be killed by any traditional
wave so putting it to bed is the only
way to actually prevent the destruction
of the world and the being who's going
to help us do this is the maiden in
black a demon in the nexus who not only
levels us up but whose sole purpose is
to put the old one to sleep she's stuck
here in the nexus as she has a nexul
binding device on her ankle the same one
we received upon being revived here this
ends up creating a very
interesting dilemma it theorized that
the maiden and black or the monumentals
are the cause of the second scourge the
crestfall of warrior says that the
monumental survived the old one on a
whim and that they're trapping us here
so that they can undo their mistake
although this could just be second hand
knowledge meaning he's an unreliable
source the monumental also mentions
though how the pantheon on the top floor
of the nexus is to give thanks to the
brave warriors who must fight to reverse
their sins either he means the sins of
man who were greedy and had a lust for
power or the sins of the monumentals for
reawakening the old one as for the
maiden and black she's stuck here in the
nexus like we are but it's possible that
she's been alive since the first scourge
and thus hasn't been able to leave since
sue was brought here she also seems to
have an odd relationship with the old
one she summons the old one to the beach
so that we may go inside and put it to
sleep but she talks to it like it's an
old friend and says that she has done
what the old one has asked her to do
almost like she and the old one have
been working together for some time this
would connect to the fact that she is
indeed a demon that probably came from
the old one but why is she working
against him to put him to sleep if she's
a demon her demon soul also allows us to
buy the soul sucker spell which is
almost identical to the spell used by
false king alantu we'll talk about later
which would mean that she taught him the
spell and leads to the theory that she
purposely taught alond about the soul
arts and the old one with the intended
effect that she'll be able to die no
matter the outcome and can finally leave
the nexus it's an absolutely fascinating
theory and creates the sense of dread as
it's unclear who we the player should
actually be trusting this whole
situation relates to another common
theme of the souls games and that's
cycles demon's souls has its own cycles
but it's more in tune with bloodborne's
idea of cycles in bloodborne it was the
thumerians who discovered the great ones
and then eventually after knowledge of
their existence had disappeared for a
while it was the yarnamites who
discovered the great ones again this is
just like in demon souls as the people
of the world during the time of the
monumental's life discovered the soul
arts which caused the rise of the old
one and now it's old kangalanta has
restarted this cycle if we manage to put
it to sleep again it's inevitable that
the old one will awake again after
someone else discovers what was supposed
to be long forgotten to actually put
this beast away though we need to cut
off its supply chains that it no longer
has a way to gather souls which means we
need to defeat the archdemons there is
one archdemon per arch stone which means
we need to kill five in order to
progress i say five because there is a
sixth art stone but it's broken there
doesn't seem to be an in-lore
explanation as to why but cut content
reveals that it was going to be in the
game but this was possibly cut due to
time or budget constraints so in order
to make sense of this anomaly we could
just say that the fog had overtaken the
archstone and thus made it inaccessible
with that in mind naturally we should
start with the first archstone which
belongs to the small king but demon's
souls does things differently with its
gameplay think of each archstone as a
different world as each one is vastly
different than the other this also means
that all npc and lore are enclosed
within this one world you'll never meet
an npc in this game that goes to a
different art stone but given how the
human brain works we'll we'll just go
from left to right in that order but
that won't work either each archstone is
also known as worlds and each world has
levels within them so the very first
level of the game would be called world
one one after defeating the boss of
world one one we then go to world one
two until we reach the final level but
world one blocks the player from
finishing it as it requires the death of
an archdemon to progress it sounds like
a headache and it is but i love this
system as this makes each playthrough
unique the concept of worlds and levels
is also never mentioned in game as it's
only something the community created to
help simplify the location names so a
new player will have no idea whether a
specific world is harder than another
and may have to alternate constantly
until they finish it's such a fantastic
idea as this allows for some
replayability as you can switch up which
worlds you tackle first but the first
world everyone must do is one one this
acts as a long tutorial and is such a
great start to the game because of what
it means for it going forward demon
souls is initially a very hard game and
it's the only game in the franchise to
keep me emotionally in sync with the
character i'm playing the main reason
for this is two specific decisions
demon souls has no bonfires and no
infinite healing item every time the
player dies they must respawn back at
the archstone before the start of the
level this plays into some of the level
design as there could be shortcuts that
make it feel like actual progress is
being made but not all of them have this
some levels are just genuinely 5 to 10
minute walks to a boss room this ties
into the healing system which is similar
to dark souls 2 and bloodborne except
there's a key difference the main item
used in bloodborne regarding healing is
blood vials you can only regain them by
buying them or finding them as loot
drops however they are consistent in the
sense they always heal the same amount
dark souls 2s of life gems are
inconsistent as there's different
variations of life gems that heal
different amounts of health but that
game also has an estus flask so life
gems are like a secondary option demon
souls has the drop style of blood vials
but the inconsistency of the life gems
meaning your only source of healing in
this game is various different types of
grass that all heal different amounts of
health and can drop at wildly different
rates couple this with the fact that
death can mean a complete reset of
progress you could be wasting 5 to 10
healing items just to die in the boss
room and have to do it all over again
with less supplies this is what i meant
before by being in sync with the
character i was playing more passive
than ever before and i was nervous
throughout all my encounters because i
knew that if i got greedy and tried to
speed things up it could cost me the
whole run so spending an extra two to
three minutes fighting all the enemies
in my way was worth it if it meant that
failure was a complete reset after some
time this feeling went away as i got
more in tune with the game's combat and
also had a nice steady supply of moon
grass but initially it was a very steep
and uphill battle just like in dark
souls demon's souls has this idea of
souls being the essence of life and
without souls were just mindless husks
if any game had convinced me that i
would become a mindless host it was
going to be demon's souls some of the
levels are painfully difficult to
navigate and it has a consistent theme
that the levels are harder than the
bosses and it's this statement i'm a
little torn on the bosses of this game
are
subpar at best world one probably has
the best boss design given the
progression of the game the first two
bosses of world 1 are the phanlinks and
the tower knight both of which are
gimmick bosses throughout the level are
fire bombs in turpentine both of which
do fire damage and the reason they're
placed here is that they're getting the
player to think outside the box
firebombs can decimate the phalanx's
defenses which allows you to create an
opening so you can hit the core which
pairs pretty well with the turpentine as
it buffs your weapon with flame damage
it's not just showing the player how to
use items to their advantage but that
the bosses going forward could have
alternate ways to defeat them this ties
into the tower knight who doesn't really
require much thinking but the idea of
hitting its legs until it falls over so
you can do some maximum damage is pretty
cool gimmick bosses are great and i like
the idea of making the players switch up
their playstyle and forcing them to
think more about their surroundings but
while the gimmicks are great the bosses
attached to most of them are just
depressingly bad which is why i'm so
glad they dropped the gimmicks and made
a proper boss fight in the last levels
of world 1. funny enough these two
bosses the penetrator and the false king
alant are my favorite bosses in the game
it's funny because these are the final
two bosses before you get to the ending
it took until the final moments of the
game until i finally became invested in
the combat these two actually required
me to think about their moves and how to
punish appropriately rather than just
hitting it until it dies with no regard
to my health or its attacks the reason
i'm torn on the bosses that i don't know
the intention behind them many of the
modern souls games have bosses be this
grand event that is the final challenge
of a level they are in a way separate
from the main level preceding them
because the difficulty of these beings
is so drastic compared to the enemies
before the fog wall and of course the
game also provides bonfires to the
player so it feels like a checkpoint
demon soul seems to want the bosses to
be integrated into the world as part of
the puzzle it's like okay so you've
gotten through dozens of enemies and
managed to overcome all the obstacles
we've thrown at you so here's the final
obstacle before you officially beat the
level but we're just gonna ramp up the
difficulty slightly so it's not too easy
for you future titles make the bosses
feel separate in a way thanks to the
bonfires and that's not a bad thing at
all the reason i mention this is because
if from software wanted to make bosses
this grand spectacle and a way to cap
off the level like in the future souls
games well they failed miserably but if
they wanted to make the bosses one more
minor hurdle the player has to jump
through then for the most part they
succeeded because the difficulty of
these bosses is laughably easy for a
souls game an easy boss is almost a
miracle as it makes the long and arduous
journey just a little easier but when a
majority of the game is plagued with it
it becomes a problem especially when the
game prides itself on difficulty once
again this is a subjective opinion as
everyone will have different experiences
and that is initially what i thought was
the issue since i'm more in tune with
the future souls games faster pace so
the older games feel a lot slower to me
by default to compare though i looked at
dark souls 1 as both of these games have
slower combat compared to the rest of
the franchise despite being similar in
pace i still found myself learning move
sets and finding punishes in dark souls
1. whereas in demon souls i was just
hitting things until i died without even
caring about my health this mostly
affected the gimmick fights which is a
good chunk of the roster but even bosses
that were just straight up one-on-one
battles like every boss in world 5 were
all just defeated using this method i
know that's more of a gameplay analysis
rather than a story one but the reason i
mention this is that boss fights in just
about every game especially the souls
games are supposed to cap off the
journey and the emotional payoff needs
to be there in order for it to feel
memorable think about all the bosses
across the souls games that you enjoy
and how their difficulty and challenge
lives up to their stories and how these
bosses are more memorable due to the
amazing lore design and combat
surrounding them this is something i'd
hope demon souls would have included
especially given how much this game had
started for the series in general but
that wasn't there getting back on track
we're still in world 1 which is the
kingdom of bulletaria this kingdom as
stated in the intro is ruled by king
lott the bosses of this area are the
phalanx tower knight penetrator and
false king alant but oddly enough
they're all fakes false king alan drops
the false demon soul implying that this
is just a demonic representation of the
real king alant and not the actual one
as for the others well according to an
npc of world one called ostrava he says
that king alant has a round table of
brave knights three of which were alfred
knight of the tower metas knight of the
lance and longbow ullan and his fearsome
legions each of these knights represents
the demons we face we also get to see
the black phantom versions of these
knights and they further connect to the
three demons we just talked about alfred
being the nut of the tower is pretty
self-explanatory but he also wields a
giant spear and shield if he needed
further connection metas drops the
penetrator sword which is the same sword
wielded by the penetrator and longbow
ullan was a ranged fighter with multiple
allies similar to the phalanx who not
only surrounds itself with multiple
other beings but can throw these spears
at range one thing this highlights is
demon soul's method of storytelling
which is all environmental and one of
the most bizarre decisions i've seen
from this game it decided to not include
lore with the boss souls something that
would be a staple for consistent lore
starting with dark souls 1 is not
present in this game this has its
positives and negatives as we'll
eventually see but for now the
environmental storytelling takes over
and it's really well done this carries
over to the npcs as well as ostrava has
a unique backstory to him olstrava is
actually a prince named ariona who came
back to bolataria to find his father
king alant this random knight is part of
the royal family which may correlate to
his fighting ability as he seems to get
stuck in multiple different places and
needs our help every time his equipment
references how his weapon and shield
belong to a legendary knight which would
mean him but if he was so legendary why
does he need our help every time we see
him this seems to imply that he's trying
to be a knight or at least seem like he
is one when he really isn't which is a
nice play on the familiar trope of
people in royalty not knowing how to
fight in combat and preferred to fight
diplomatically or at the very least let
someone else do the fighting for them
our final encounter with ostrava is on
these stairs before the false king
alarmed boss fight where he discovers
the real truth it's unclear whether he
fought king alant and then succumbed to
his wounds or killed himself since he
just magically dies here but what's more
interesting though is shortly after he
invades us as a black phantom this form
is similar to the three round table
nights from earlier and from what i can
gather turning into a black phantom is
when someone loses their willpower or
purpose similar to going hollow in dark
souls this isn't the real ostrava he
wouldn't willingly attack us after
everything we've done for him and he
wouldn't defend the boss as it not only
is a fake version of his actual father
but he tells us to kill it for him which
is why it leads me to that conclusion
the key he gives us though will take us
to a mausoleum and in here is a weapon
called the demon brand i like the
connection of this weapon to king a lot
as the weapon has a counterpart called
soulbrandt demon branch does more damage
when a person's soul is more pure and
human but soul brant does more damage
when a soul is more demonic which makes
sense why demon brand is here and why
king allant wields soul brand as he was
obsessed with demonic power combining
the two will actually give us the
northern regalia a magical weapon of
unprecedented power but stopping us from
getting one of the parts of the weapon
is old king doran he might also be the
being on the arch stone as the green
emerald connects to his green color
palette and he's also considered an old
king plus he's also a demi-god according
to various item descriptions so he may
have been alive during the time of the
first scourge but that's just a theory
of mine what is rather upsetting though
is that to my knowledge this is the only
reference to someone being a demigod in
this game and i found this to be a
severely missed opportunity it's just
sort of left here without any
explanation as to why especially when
you realize that he was locked in here
possibly by false king alant when he
took over boletaria which begs the
question how this demigod got
overpowered by a demon this easily the
only thing i can think of is that
because he is the royal protector of
boletaria he may have just been
following the orders of who we thought
was king alont until he was then
betrayed regardless though it's weird
how this is never brought up again they
just sort of said he was a demigod and
then just left it at that the other
notable mpc in bolataria is yuria the
witch we can learn about her location
from another npc called beor of the twin
fangs the other twin fang if you
remember is valorfax the one who escaped
the fog when it first arrived
interestingly though valorfax may have
actually come back but died when
reaching the castle bjor has a ring
called the ring of strength that is only
given to the twin fangs the only other
place we can find this ring is
underneath this dragon next to a pile of
bodies so he may have been defeated by
one of the dragons that now resides in
boletaria as i said before bjor points
us to yuria and her story is quite
depressing we can find her in a secret
location only accessible to the player
if they have the hat of an official
these officials came shortly before the
demon scourge occurred and will appear
in the next world when we discuss that
soon they also seem to have a sort of
agenda as they hold a great deal of
power in bolataria and possibly want to
serve a demon king which in this case
would be false king alant many of the
fat officials are seen in bulletaria
guarding the way towards false king
alone so this theory could have some
weight to it what we do know is that
they indulge in very sinful behaviors as
they are described as gluttonous
monsters which connect to their
appearance but they seem to have a lust
or hatred towards women stockpile thomas
is an npc in the nexus who lost his wife
and daughter and we can find their
corpses in the first level his
daughter's body has an ornament on it
but his wife has these raggedy robes
just like the ring of strength this
clothing item is only found here and on
yuria if we kill her it's possible that
it could just be a coincidence but
assuming there isn't that would imply
that thomas's wife was a witch this also
connects to yuria as thomas's wife was
hung and tortured from what we assume
was the practice of witchcraft and it
seems like yuria had a similar
punishment although hers may be a bit
more severe as it seems like they
purposely put her in this tower so that
they could assault her bjor's dialogue
says quote according to that spineless
warden a young sorceress is being held
prisoner there where she's subjected to
um all manner of untold acts in the name
of purification end quote this implies
that yuria was sexually assaulted and
possibly by quite a few officials since
this is their sort of secret base for
the group only accessible to them due to
this she has completely thrown away her
reasoning for coming to bolataria in the
first place which is to gain power
through demon souls as now that idea
isn't even on her mind anymore the only
thing she can do is become a merchant
for the player if they want to learn
some dark arts but she'll actually
encourage us not to learn her magic as
she explains that being a witch has
brought her a great deal of pain in her
life and she does not want that to come
to us it's a really grim backstory but
the one reason i'm upset about this is
that we never get a quest line for yuria
but the reason behind that feeling
mostly stems from the fact that yuria is
such a sweet and kind person and to have
that happen to her really affects you as
the player i wanted to be able to help
her in any way that i could but the game
never gave me the opportunity to do so
at the very least it does end up making
the player hate the fat officials more
as they are clearly shown to be monsters
with no concept of morality or even a
basic understanding of human rights as a
whole boletaria was a great world in
demon souls it's not my personal
favorite but it was a really great start
to the game it ended up being the first
and last world i explored due to the
progression of the game and because of
how well it was crafted it started and
ended my playthrough on a really good
note stonefang tunnel is our next world
and it belongs to the king of the
burrowers they're a group of people who
lived in these tunnels and would
dedicate their whole day to the mining
of the tunnels the hearthstone seems to
imply that they served under king alan
since they were working with bolataria
but since it's now been overrun by the
fat officials it would seem that they
are trying to reap the benefits of the
mining town which would explain why
there are quite a few of them in these
tunnels due to the group's undying
dedication to keep mining it's no wonder
why so many of them despite being
mindless they'll continue to work their
condition though does raise a few
questions these beings in the tunnels
are not the same as the dregling scene
in bolataria it seems that the fog
released by the old one had changed
their appearance and gave these minor
scales we could see this on blacksmith
ed who we can find down here he seems to
be the only sane one left as all the
other miners around him have been
completely transformed and who knows
after some time ed himself may fully
turn as well one thing demon's souls
really excels in is environmental design
many of these locations are built like
mazes which adds the overall depth of
the level itself 2-1 here for example is
quite a complex level and you can easily
get lost down here the location is
called the tunnel city after all so if
it's not built like an ant farm then it
doesn't really make much sense at the
end of this level is the armored spider
and he's a pretty decent boss especially
if it's encountered earlier on in the
playthrough after it though is where the
tunnel city really lives up to its name
you thought the first level was complex
well you don't even know the half of it
as this place is insanely complicated to
navigate there are various paths to go
through all of which have branching
paths from it that can either go up and
down completely leaving you confused as
to how you just spent 20 minutes down
here only to end up back at the
beginning if you somehow manage to make
it out of the tunnels you'll be shown a
pit of dragon bones next to these
weapons called the hands of god many of
the miners in the city relied on
strength as their weapon blacksmith
baldwin claims to have defeated quite a
few beer bugs in his life with his bare
hands but according to these weapons
there seems to be a person known as the
big m who defeated dragons with his bare
fists the weapon placement is also quite
intriguing as it's right next to a being
called the flame lurker who fights with
his fists it's possible that this is the
legendary big m or it could be a
manifestation to the legend this concept
of myths or fictional beings being real
is carried over into world 4 so it's not
too farfetched to assume the same is
happening here this is really the only
explanation that can be created as
without it the flame lurker has no
reason to be here this goes back to the
issue with the game not having item
descriptions on the boss souls to make
things even worse you can't even buy
items with the flame lurker soul because
it's used by ed so you can upgrade those
weapons into boss souls so since we
can't buy weapons or spells with the
soul specifically we have actually zero
information on it that is concrete other
than the fact that we know it was sealed
down here the issue is we don't know why
and this also goes for the armored
spider some speculate that it was
created by the old monk who will visit
in world 3 but there isn't too much to
connect the two other than that there
are dozens of lizards that can be found
in the cave and we can assume that they
weren't born this way and obtain this
new appearance from the gathering of
souls or by consuming the rocks or lava
in the mines this might be the only
explanation as to why the armored
spider's appearance is this way but this
too is also a very weak connection this
is why the backstory on some of these
creatures bothers me so much these two
beings are anomalies within the game
world and their decision to make the
backstories non-existent or a simple the
fog did it is not interesting in the
slightest there were some theories
revolving around the armored spider such
as it was a creation of the old monk a
creation of the fat ministers or even a
mistake due to a blade being located
near the boss room that gives the player
a weakness to magic similar how the
spiders we can assist in magic as well
all of which are extremely compelling
theories but it feels like we're just
grasping at straws we're trying to find
something anything to make sense of this
boss but it isn't involved in anything
if playing these games has taught me
anything it's that making wild theories
is more than acceptable as long as
there's a basic understanding to go off
of but with these two there's almost
nothing other than an insanely large
reach just so that we can say we know
something that's why the phrase the fog
did it is so compelling it's easy to
understand and seems probable which is
fine if this is done sparingly but as
we'll see not just later but literally
in the next few seconds it gets used
again and again behind the flame lurker
is the final boss of the level and
archdemon of world 2 the dragon god just
like we talked about before it seems
that the fog may have brought this
legend to life as the burrowers of
tunnel city had found ancient dragon
bones and thus built a shrine around it
they also made the shrine to seal it
inside the city so that it wouldn't
escape on the off chance it revived
itself however just in case that didn't
work their plan b was two giant harpoon
cannons that were capable of killing it
or at least grounding the towering beast
as you would expect the reason for its
creation was because the fog had imbued
the bones of the demon soul which caused
it to be reborn the fight is basically
running from one end of the arena to the
other and then activating the two guns
on the way afterwards the boss just sits
down and accepts its defeat while you
wail on it the whole encounter requires
zero thinking i brute forced the entire
fight i wasn't even timing my advances
or dodging when needed i was just
running a full speed and if i got hit
while the moon graphs would have topped
me off earlier i talked about how some
of the bosses may have been designed as
a part of the level's puzzle and not the
grand final fight well this is without a
doubt not that as the boss arena is
inches from the flame lurkers with zero
enemies in between so it was meant to be
this climactic moment where the player
topples a dragon while outrunning its
attacks but i didn't have this feeling
on top of having a lackluster final boss
fight world 2 also has zero interesting
npcs three out of the four are merchants
and the only one who isn't is scurvier
who wandered down here to loot items off
the deceased and got himself lost he
doesn't serve any purpose than divulging
semi-important information about the
tunnels and that's it many of the
merchants do this too by the way and i'm
not discrediting the aspect of their
characters when they do this as any
information about the level is fine by
me but in the actual context of a quest
line there isn't any his quest line just
revolved around the dragon bone smasher
weapon you can find in the dragon god
boss room and all he does is just give
you an item for it world 2 is pretty
lackluster and probably my least
favorite area in the game lore wise as
it doesn't provide enough information to
really get a grasp on what's going on
and seems to fall back on the usual the
fog did it explanation the level design
however was really well done and truly
conveys the pure insanity that comes
with a city that is underground
the land of latria is the third world
the player can explore and just from the
first few minutes you can tell that this
place is not going to have a happy
ending to start the player spawns in a
cell and soon after we'll discover that
we aren't the only ones in this prison
not only are there hundreds of other
prisoners within these cells but there
seems to be these demonic beings that
walk the halls waiting for a brave
prisoner to make an escape within the
cells of the prison are various torture
devices and judging from the equipment
that is scattered throughout the prison
it seems that many of its inhabitants
are royalty in fact the only sane being
left in the prison is this merchant who
was of royalty she explains that lottery
was ruled by a queen and her husband but
she at some point banished the husband
for an unknown reason but this wasn't
the end of his story as he returned in a
golden garb with demons following
closely behind him with this newfound
power he pillaged latria and seized
control of the kingdom the former
husband would then imprison all the
royals of latria but promised that they
could be granted redemption and ascend
if they wanted to however the royal
woman believes this ascension to be
false already the story of lautrea is
starting off incredibly strong and the
environmental storytelling continues
this streak of content many of the
prisoners are assumed to be royalty or
at least affiliated with some of the
royal family as there is some gear that
belongs to the king's spies implying
that either king allan sends spies to
keep tabs on matria or these assassins
belong to the king of latria however
being the king of latria would mean that
was the husband or at least former king
but it's also possible that the queen of
latria may have took upon another spouse
shortly after her former husband's
banishment it's been theorized that
rydel is her husband we find him
specifically in soul form which would
mean that despite dying he isn't allowed
to leave the prison which is a
particularly cruel fate this would then
connect to rydel being her new husband
and why the monk imprisoned him
eternally however rydel explains that a
retainer to the king once held the key
to his cell and describes him as an
ebony swine with a gluttonous swaying
belly which would mean that the fat
officials imprisoned him and may have a
hand in his current form the only other
prisoner of note in here is sage freak
on his own he isn't too interesting is
he's just a merchant but his presence in
the nexus does create a conflict in the
nexus you'll notice these giant steps
that lead downwards these steps put the
lower part of the nexus in half on one
side you have the magicians which are
sage freak his apprentice and yuria and
on the other side are the clerics they
seem to be at odds with one another the
midges don't seem to hate the clerics
but they definitely don't appreciate the
harsh words being shouted at them by the
clerics it's a really interesting feud
but i want to talk more about this later
when we meet saint urbain in world 4.
earlier i talked about how the tunnel
city was a maze-like structure but
that's nothing compared to the prison of
hope i must have spent an hour in this
place trying to find the exit this makes
narrative sense as it should be
difficult for the prisoners to escape as
not only are the guards blocking their
path but the layout is extremely
confusing speaking of those guards they
serve a very important purpose in the
prison as not only do they keep watch
but they also consume the souls of the
beings in this prison so that they can
be used by the archdemon who is the
husband that was banished called the old
monk to get to them though we need to
escape this prison and at the very end
is the fool's idol this boss is a
doll-like version of the queen of latria
presumably made by the old monk so the
people of the prison don't realize the
actual state of the kingdom and still
believe that the queen is alive she also
has a very interesting gimmick as the
servant located above the boss room
which can only be found outside the
bounds of the boss room revives her if
she dies meaning you'll have to take
care of him first before entering it
unless you want to keep fighting her
over and over again the boss fight is
pretty simple but i really liked the
gimmick that surrounded it according to
the royal woman she said that the people
would come here to seek redemption and
ascend which is a little ironic as not
only are we going down but this idea of
redemption was a complete lie as these
demon creatures swoop in to take us to
the next level of latria which is an
even more complex and horrific dungeon
all beings brought here were most likely
tortured and experimented on as these
weird scorpion-like creatures could be
some of the old monks experiments so
this means that the monk wasn't just
using demons but creating them in the
middle of the dungeon is this fleshy
creature that is assumed to be the
vessel that gathers souls that it can go
to the old monk it's probably one of my
favorite levels just due to the
convoluted nature of the level itself
which fits the tone of this whole arch
stone after somehow finding your way
through the entirety of the level you
may encounter a person called yurt he
from the get-go is absolutely lying to
the slayer of demons upon his rescue if
you go back to the nexus you can find a
few corpses that weren't there before he
works with a person called
mephistopheles and is a part of a group
called the soul industry which is a
society of people that meets in secret
to harness the power of soul arts both
yurt and mephistopheles plan to kill
anyone with the knowledge of soul arts
that includes many of the npcs in the
nexus and us i really like the idea of a
group of people who are inadvertently
ruining your entire playthrough
especially when you aren't aware that
yurt is the one killing the people in
the nexus he's also very hidden so even
if you piece together that it's him it's
very hard to actually find his location
this dungeon you find him in is also an
example of a level that has zero
shortcuts so any deaths will completely
revert all progress and this is made
especially maddening when you get to the
boss called the man-eater this is the
first ever duo fight in the franchise
and on paper it's good but in execution
it's pretty broken not only does the
player have to keep tabs on two demons
at once but they also have to pay
attention to the arena as it's possible
to fall off during the fight to help you
though the game provides you with these
stone pillars as cover when they start
flying but depending on who you are that
might actually make the fight even worse
in terms of quality the ai has a really
hard time trying to land on the ground
and if it fails it will just go back up
in the air again and try again which in
a way is really nice when both are alive
but when it's just one of them it's just
prolonging the fight not much is known
about the man-eaters but they seem to be
more experiments by the old monks
judging by their humanoid figure but
boss weapon descriptions talk about
there being a symbiotic relationship
between the host and the snake within
the man-eater so it seems that this
snake being used as a tail is another
entity in the man-eater or maybe
controlling it in some way past the
man-eater is the old monk himself a
human wearing a cloak that is bigger
than him and stretches to the ends of
the room we learn however that the old
monk is not in control the golden garb
is not just a unique design piece it
seems to be a sentient being that was
using the monk as its vessel boss
weapons related to the soul say quote if
you have no future to lose then who
could blame you for placing your faith
in the golden robes and the old man was
nothing more than a medium for the robes
that drove men mad the spell reflects
the old man's nature to urine for power
that was not his end quote it's a
genuinely interesting twist as it makes
the monk out to be less sinister than
what is presumed or at least that's what
it seems like the golden garb could have
either wanted to create demons for the
sake of power or may have taken the
emotions and feelings of the old monk a
being who was just recently stripped of
his power and yearned for more and used
that to create what we see in latria now
maybe the golden garb isn't inherently
evil but rather intensifies the feelings
of the user and gives them the means to
accomplish their goals and for the monk
though that seemed to be quite sinister
i would talk about the boss itself but i
think it's pretty obvious how i feel on
the subject and i've probably already
beaten the boss by the time we finish
talking about the monk according to the
wiki it's possible that a player can be
summoned for the fight which is
definitely a nice gimmick and one i
enjoyed thanks to half light and dark
souls 3 but given that i'm playing the
game offline and it's from 2009 and i'm
95 certain the server shut down a few
years ago no one's gonna be summoned for
this fight even though that does dampen
the quality of the fight the npc that
will appear by default could have at
least been a bit interesting but it's
pretty bad and that goes for most of the
fighting when it involves npcs or
humanoid targets this game has poise and
stagger weaved into the gameplay like
the early souls games so when axe can
stagger an enemy pretty consistently and
seeing as they refuse to dodge even when
caught in this five to six wing combo it
makes the fight so much easier i'm not
sure how lighter weapons like daggers
work but at least for me the axe made
the fight laughably easy and this is
only going to get worse as we continue
lottery though was a great level and had
some fantastic backstory that revolved
around an entity not related to the old
one which gave it the uniqueness the
level had despite some minor gripes with
the bosses though it was a pretty good
level world 4 is the shrine of storms
and this level is interesting to say the
least the shrine of storms was an island
shrine used by the shadow men a
long-lost group of people who mourned
the dead by worshiping the sky this
group of pagans believed in various
different beings called the adjudicator
and storm king all of whom were related
to the process of death in their culture
they may have also believed in a being
called the old hero but his backstory is
a little confusing but we'll get to that
in a moment the fog however took this
idea and made what used to be an
imagination into reality which is why
these three bosses are real beings in
the shrine of storms it's not a terrible
backstory even if it is just a slightly
altered version of world 2 except for
the fact that the archdemons of both
worlds are literally the same thing as
they were both seen as gods by the
people of that region that have been
either created or revived by the old one
i just feel like there could have been
such better backstories for these demons
what could have been an interesting
development in my eyes as if the shadow
men were actually alive and we got to
see their reaction to their gods now
made demons and see if they still pray
to them or are terrified that something
went wrong since the demons are most
likely killing people not because
they're rituals but just because they're
demons i've always been fascinated by
what could happen if a person or god
someone adores or worships turns out not
to be who they think they are does that
person lose faith do they continue and
ignore it or do they accept it i feel
like this could have been an interesting
idea to bring into the game but sadly
the shadow men are dead so we're never
able to explore that what i do find
rather interesting is that we
inadvertently have to take part in the
ritual as the bosses are ordered in the
same way the cultural legend is told the
adjudicator is the first boss and is
also pretty terrible not only is he just
a copy of the tower knight but with a
different weak point but the moveset on
this demon is hilariously bad dodging or
blocking is not even a requirement all
that matters that you hug its left hip
and walk i'm almost certain this boss
has more moves on the ground like this
but the fact that i can manipulate its
ai this easily by just sitting in one
location is pretty pathetic the reason
for the adjudicator in regards to their
culture is that this being acts as a
warden of sorts the judge souls that
pass on and to make sure they're worthy
enough to continue the process past the
adjudicator is a catacomb of spirits and
skeletons that are possibly the old
warriors that passed on ages ago down
here is also patches who will kick us
into a hole like usual but we aren't
alone down here as saint urbain is
located here as well he is the main
leader of the clerics and is seen in
such high regard as one of the members
is willing to literally give up all her
possessions to urbane to show how
devoted she is to god as i said earlier
though there seems to be a feud between
the clerics and the mages and saint
germain is mainly the one to blame for
this because he doesn't speak very
highly of the mages and says that their
magic originated from the old ones
however sage freak even agrees with him
and just straight up tells us it does
but freak also mentions that while it
does sound bad at least he admits it
unlike the clerics who hide their own
god this is tied to various items in the
game that seem to claim that the god the
clerics pray to is actually the old one
and that they're being deceived magical
arts are a creation of the old one that
means soul arts and miracles the mages
saw this as a newfound art with a dark
past and the cleric saw miracles as a
sign from god to fight back against the
corruption of the old one it could also
be that saint urbain knows this and has
convinced himself that this isn't true
which ends up causing a weird clash
between the two groups as one accepts
their magic is from the old one while
the other hides it one thing i found
rather interesting about the miracles is
that they seem to serve an actual
purpose many of the descriptions call
the miracles counter signs like god's
wrath being a counter sign for the
dragon god it's like they're taking the
soul and harnessing its power from the
demon and using it in a specific way
it's not like the future souls games
where you can just get a boss soul and
then get a lightning spell from it for
example even if it does make sense
because this seems to intentionally be
made this way within the game's lore
which fits with saint urbain's dialogue
on how he thought miracles were used to
fight back against the demons so having
miracles be counter signs from a demon's
soul makes narrative sense in that hole
that saint urbain was trapped in is
where the legendary sword called makato
resides which we can give to satsuki who
claims it's his father's satsuki is
lying though and is just tricking us
into giving him the sword due to his
lust for power but the fight and quest
pretty much all end here and it's really
boring the reason is because it's once
again affected by demon souls combat
where i can drain half his health bar in
just a few seconds it just makes the
whole encounter really pointless as his
entire quest starts and ends the moment
you talk to him so he serves zero
purpose to the level at the end of this
specific level is the old hero he's a
fairly decent boss fight and the gimmick
for him was something i found rather
interesting he is blind so by equipping
the thief ring it makes the player
harder to detect which causes him to
swing wildly at anything he touches
which allows you to get more hits in the
beauty of the gimmick is that there are
only two rings found in this game and
they're only in two different worlds
that aren't world four so it's not like
the failings fight where the items are
within the level you have to go out of
your way to find this he's also pretty
quick pace wise so it was definitely a
really solid fight the old hero's
backstory is pretty interesting as this
backstory isn't that concrete but the
interpretations of his story are rather
fascinating one is that he is the ideal
representation of a soldier in their
culture there is very little lore to go
off of to prove this point but given
that he's mere inches from the storm
king arena and dressed in these ornate
pieces of jewelry perhaps the shadow men
spoke of a being called the old hero a
being who was dedicated to the storm
king and was thus granted a proper
burial and that his journey should be
the template that those of the shadow
men should follow if they want to
appease the storm king however on the
other hand it could also be an
interpretation of the opposite as you
can see him tied up in the intro
cutscene and given various item
descriptions calling him the seeker of
storms it's possible that he wanted to
conquer the storm king instead of
appeasing it this could correlate to the
ruler weapon in the arena behind him
which does damage to the storm king as
we'll see also considering the fact he's
tied up it's possible that the shadow
man caught wind of this betrayal and
forced him to watch as better warriors
go on into the afterlife in peace while
he's stuck here for life i'm genuinely
fascinated by this boss as there's so
many contradicting ideas that his
imprisonment here and his relationship
with the storm king could mean anything
and speaking of the storm king he's our
final boss in the archdemon of world 4.
this boss just like the previous two
also has a gimmick involved but it
requires the use of the storm ruler
modern souls players will recognize the
name from the yorm boss fight in dark
souls 3 and this is where the
inspiration came from it's exactly like
that fight as well as it's a giant beast
that can only be defeated by the use of
one weapon this of course means the
fight will be quite simple and it is but
the presentation of this fight is
exemplary the remake also makes this
look even better since it adds weather
effects to the arena making it feel like
an actual storm is present the storm
king also has one of my favorite
character designs in the game due to its
alien-like features making it really
feel like a true spawn of a demon the
shrine of storms is pretty hard to rank
as there was a mixed bag of fantastic
and questionable additions within this
level the npcs were pretty dull boss
fights were hit or miss and the
backstories were similar in that respect
the fact that to progress in the level
we have to take part in the cultural
ritual was pretty cool but i do wish
more could have been done surrounding
the shadow men and their gods as the
dynamic between them and the inevitable
destruction that could have followed
could honestly been one of the best
worlds in the game the valley of
defilement is our final world and if you
ever wondered where miyazaki got this
idea to start adding swamps into souls
games well it probably originated here
because this place is an absolute mess
never mind the fact that this level is a
convoluted jumble of trash and filth but
couple that with the game's core
mechanics we talked about you're gonna
be running through this area a lot just
to find your way back it's incredibly
annoying but it's one of the best
looking levels in the game and is in
complete sync with the tone that
surrounds the level itself similar to
blighttown and the gutter that would
shortly follow after this game this
place was just a trash heap of the
kingdom where all the beings that were
seen as unfit to live in the kingdom
were put here anyone from criminals to
neglected and abused citizens would be
down here after hearing about this
society of people who were thrown away a
woman named saint estrella came down
here in order to help these beings and
traveling with her was her night girl
vinland however despite her good
intention she may have actually been
causing more pain than before estrella
seemed to believe that the only way to
save them was to put them out of their
misery which is why she became an
archdemon and outtakes their souls souls
in demon souls are the essence of life
so by taking that away she'd be ridding
him of all their thoughts and feelings
but while this may take away any happy
emotions it would also have removed the
bad ones making them a mindless creature
in the process it's a heartbreaking tale
as she probably had good intentions but
the actions that followed were anything
but one of the miracles you can buy from
her soul really says it best quote
estrella who willingly accepted the
corrupted and corroded naturally became
the most corrupted of them all and quote
it's a shame that her altruistic mindset
was pushed this far as it caused
thousands to suffer because of it the
reason things got this way was that she
was starting to lose faith in god she
was confused as to why something like
this would be accepted under god's rule
and was concerned if she was truly
serving a being worthy of her praise as
i said earlier in world 4 i love this
idea and being able to see what occurred
as a result of her losing faith was
fascinating but before we get to her
though we need to fight two bosses the
leechmonger and dirty colossus one is a
sentient being that was born when
various leeches were combined with the
demon soul and the other is a sentient
creature that was born when various
pieces of filth and trash were combined
with a demon soul noticing a pattern
well that's one interpretation of them
in the valley of defilement are a few
weapons one of them is called the
estrella this weapon increases the
wielder's resistance to plague and
poison and was wielded by a holy knight
who most likely either accompanied saint
estrella down here with garl vinland or
came here to find her once the news of
her abandonment had spread this is
rather interesting as the legimonger's
boss soul can create the cure miracle
which increases resistance to plague and
disease this means that this could be
the holy night similar to how the tower
knight is a modified version of alfred
knight of the tower this could also be a
stretch and most likely an attempt by me
to avoid having to say the phrase the
fog did it again but i won't have to
wait too long as the dirty colossus
seems to be just that there doesn't seem
to be any defining items or details that
point to it being anything other than
that however what this boss means is
rather interesting as it's basically a
manifestation of the valley itself this
beast is covered in death decay filth
and trash all of which are present in
the valley so essentially this is the
living embodiment of the location once
again i think you can already tell how
much i don't like these fights from the
gameplay which is a good thing because i
actually want to focus on the next boss
which may have created the funniest
encounter i've had in the soul series to
date the final boss of the level is made
in australia you don't actually fight
her as she will summon garl vinland to
defend her and if you happen to defeat
him first then she'll commit suicide
shortly after fighting girl vinlan is a
cakewalk not only does he suffer from
the same issues as the old monk but from
software for some reason decided to
place the guy with the largest hammer
possible in the lowest ceiling possible
meaning his hammer will bounce
constantly i think what was meant to
happen was the player was supposed to
fall in the pit beside him and fight him
there which would make things definitely
harder but if that was the case then
make the pit the only part of the level
so they're forced to fight him there
he'll also come back as a black phantom
if you revisit the area and the same
issue occurs there defeating garo will
make him drop his family crest which can
be given to his sister but nothing
really comes of this she basically came
here in search of her brother since
saint estrada had left the church and
she was trying to see if the rumors were
true but she got stuck in the valley of
defilement and couldn't find him despite
some of the initial criticism from a
pure story perspective this is the best
world in the game the level design
upholds the tone of the levels and not
just in the fact that it is a headache
to navigate but in the smaller details
like the primitive design of both the
buildings and the creatures equipment
the backstory about sainastra changed my
mind about this whole area and made me
look at it from a different light as not
just a place that was dying but a place
that was subjected to punishment then
only be subjected to more once a person
with incredible privilege thought that
they could make the world a better place
because they're such a nice person with
a kind heart during our journey through
demon souls you may have noticed more
negative opinions than i usually display
and this is ultimately due to the way
the game handles its core story the
premise was great and was able to
captivate me from the very beginning but
what i was worried about ended up coming
true writing about demons can be boring
as they all fall back on the same story
that they were all created from one
being or one event and that they don't
have any other reason for existing other
than the fact that they just do that's
what many of the bosses in this game
could be boiled down to demons who were
created due to the fog and the power of
the demon soul more than half of this 17
boss roster falls into this category so
it's no secret why i enjoyed world 3's
bosses so much because it actually
decided to do something different the
golden garb to our knowledge is just
another entity although it's possible
the fog may have created that too
regardless it wasn't a normal story
about demons being created since it
involved a former ruler who was wronged
in his life and wanted revenge what
could have been a nice change was taking
the idea of creating demons and twisting
it such as my idea for world 4 which is
that i wanted the shadow men to see
their deities and gods and then uncover
what they would think about this
discovery i wanted something more to be
done with the three demons of world one
why them specifically was it pure luck
or were their souls more demonic than it
seemed there's never an answer i wanted
the fog and the old one to bring out the
worst in people and their thoughts not
just create things for the sake of
creation and if i'm being honest i
probably would have accepted that last
part too but only in small doses to our
knowledge all the bosses of world one
two four and the dirty colossus of five
are just creations of the fog three of
the knights of the round table now have
demonic versions of themselves but we
don't know why them specifically the
armored knight flame lurker and dragon
god just seem to be creations of the fog
as nothing else opposes this idea all
the beings of world 4 are pretty
obviously creations of the old one and
the fog and the same probably goes for
the dirty colossus that is a lot of
bosses and that's upsetting because the
bosses are a major part of this game's
story and it's these beings that were
treated the worst but now that we've
killed all the demons in our way and
shut off all the supply chains that the
old one relied on we can now enter the
land beneath the nexus and confront the
old one the maiden in black takes us
down to its layer and we can enter the
beast itself the reason the old one
accepted us so willingly is that we cut
off its way to gain more souls and thus
more power so now it lets us in with the
hope that it will join it and become its
new host like kangalant speaking of
kangalan to get to the old one we need
to kill him first and in typical souls
fashion it is a very anti-climactic but
very intentional boss fight the way king
alont has presented to the player is
showing to them that being the host is
not the correct choice and that this
idea of gaining power is not worth the
suffering that has been endured if we
accept the old one's offer despite this
kangalan still agrees with his decision
it even calls us a fool for killing him
and says that no one wishes to go on
anymore king allant believes that the
world would be a better place if
everything was wiped out which is likely
why he joined the old one in its quest
to eradicate the world but king elon's
opinion doesn't matter as he's not the
slayer of demons from here we're given
two options let the maiden and black
fulfill her duty and let the old one
sleep or kill her and join the old one
like king a lot if we do the good ending
we see the maiden in black and the old
one are sent back to where the old one
came from all knowledge of soul arts is
a race though which means magic and
miracles are gone but at least the world
isn't on the brink of extinction none of
the souls that were lost during this
time though will not be returned to the
owners so anyone who died during the
scourge is going to stay dead and the
slayer of demons also becomes a
monumental and will likely watch over
the nexus until the next scourge if we
do the bad ending well
it's actually pretty much what i just
explained we join the old one and
eradicate the world simple as that
surprisingly these endings don't leave a
lot up to the imagination they're pretty
self-explanatory which is honestly a
welcome sight for the series considering
how wild some of the endings will get in
the future titles but these are the two
endings of demon souls which means we've
now officially come to the end of the
game it takes a lot for me to truly hate
something and demon souls is no such
game i still plan on playing this again
i have various magical builds i'd like
to try out and i haven't even played the
remake yet so i still have more to
experience with this game but even
though i will continue to play and enjoy
the game that doesn't mean it's without
faults depending on the level the bosses
and their backstories were hit or miss
there were fantastic stories like the
old monk and saint estrella but there
was also some pretty mediocre ones like
the armored spider and the dragon god
one thing that was easily one of the
best parts of this game was the level
design each one was excellent and i
can't think of a single level i
genuinely hated the value of defilement
is one of the best levels i've seen from
this series to date and stonefeng tunnel
has such a wonderfully confusing and
infuriating design that perfectly mimics
a tunneled city this division between
content that was good and content that
was bad though makes it hard to say for
certain whether the game is truly good
or bad which is why i consider it decent
no game is without faults this much is
true but it depends on the severity of
those faults the pushback from content
that doesn't contain any faults and how
much it affects the player's experience
as a whole and demon's souls had a lot i
like and quite a bit i disliked but
ultimately i still think it's a game
worth playing
as i said earlier this is the final
episode of our soulsborne series
eldering is still in its infancy and i
want to wait to all the dlc is out
before i make a video on it as some of
the main game's questions could be
answered with a dlc so in the meantime
it's time to discuss some other games
there is a lot of series i would like to
discuss that fit the current genre of
what we're talking about the third
person rpgs but also plenty of other
games and other genres as well so expect
those videos to have the same level of
quality as these did just on different
material before we jump into a series
though i may also look into a few souls
likes to really put a cap on this whole
thing but i'm either debating on doing a
dozen or so with short summaries in one
video or having dedicated videos to just
a couple holodine and blasphemous for
example have been on my radar for quite
a while and i feel like they might need
their own videos but do let me know what
sounds better to you regardless thank
you girl for watching today and be sure
to like and subscribe if you're new as
always thank you to my returning viewers
for coming back to another video and
with that take care everyone
goodbye
you